if you're willing to suffer
and I mean suffer your brain and your
body once connected together can do
anything
it's about the grind it's about the
obstacles it's about the challenges it's
about the pain
that you endure along the way for that
30 seconds
of being able to either
stand on the platform
be acknowledged by individuals that are
close to you
but when that happens
your mind has to immediately shift back
because now
you felt and tasted something that you
could only get through winning
are you willing to do it again
you have to do the process the process
is non-negotiable it's just you have to
do it
all right so if you have to do something
I don't have highs about it or lows
about it I know it has to get done and
if I let my emotions get involved in it
why it's not going to get done to its
best abilities
so if people say you got to love the
process and then something comes in the
process that you don't really love
because there's no way everybody loves
100 of any process I mean every day I
mean since you know 20 years it was an
everyday process and trying to figure
out strengths and weaknesses for example
jumping ability now my vertical was a 40
it wasn't a 46 or 40 45. my hands are
big but they're not massive right so you
got to figure out ways to strengthen
them so your hands are strong enough to
be able to Palm a ball and do the things
that you need to do quickness I was
quick but not insanely quick I was fast
but not ridiculously fast right so I had
to
rely on skill a lot more I had to rely
on angles a lot more I had to study the
game a lot more and uh but I enjoyed it
though so like from the time I was I
can't remember when I started watching
the game I studied the game and it just
never changed the mentality is a really
simple one in the sense that the
confidence comes from preparation
you know so when the game's on the line
I'm not asking myself to do something
that I haven't done thousands of times
before right so when I'm prepared I know
what I'm capable of doing I know I'm
comfortable doing and I know what I'm
not comfortable doing
all right so in those moments if it
looks like um ice cold or not nervous
it's because I've done it thousands of
times before so it's one more time when
I said I wanted to win eight gold medal
is basically half the people in the
swimming World thought I was absolutely
crazy and nobody could ever do something
like that but for me I was somebody who
believed in it and somebody who believed
in the process of getting there I knew
it wasn't going to happen overnight like
I said before but every little small
thing that we did was a small stepping
stone in order to in order to even be
able to have that chance and that
opportunity to to do what I did in 2008
because at that time at the Olympic
Games
that's a tough I mean that's where I
think the real truth comes out because I
think there are a lot of people who are
very talented who can make it there
there are very few people who can deal
with the pressure and the stress that
happens when we're there
so that's why I say we had to make sure
that we were physically emotionally and
mentally ready because I had to be ready
to be able to kind of manage my emotions
through that week yeah winning a gold
medal is absolutely incredible there's
nothing better than standing on the
podium listening to your national anthem
play after you just won a gold medal but
for me I'm somebody who I knew that I
had
seven other events after the first day
so I have to throw that in the back of
my head I got to throw that race out
even though if I you know even like you
know wait I broke a world record one
goal you know won my first gold medal
like like I was like cool like things
are starting really well so I have to
put that behind me to then get ready for
the next race when the time comes to
focus on the game I focus on my athletic
skills and putting it together with the
team and somehow collectively going out
and doing a job each and every day I
challenge myself
to be the best basketball player every
moment that I'm playing the game of
basketball and sometimes that means
tricking yourself in your mind to say
that you can't do this or your
weaknesses are here but yet you still
try to work on improving those
weaknesses a lot of people may say well
Michael Jordan never had weaknesses
Michael Jordan had weaknesses he just
had to dig deep inside himself to figure
out what they were and challenge himself
to improve those weaknesses so mentally
I like to challenge myself to go out and
play a perfect basketball game although
I know you can't do that is practically
impossible to play a perfect game but
that doesn't mean you can't challenge
yourself to do that
understanding there's no replacement for
persistence as simplistic as that is
it's like you know disappointment either
destroys you or drives you and you have
to decide which one it's going to be if
you don't consciously decide there's
always going to be more BS for you to
deal with if you're resourceful you can
get the money you can get the time you
can get the energy you can get anything
you want and you've got to get over your
fear to be resourceful so we do
experiences that are so physiologically
profound that those fears do not stop
you anymore yeah and that's what that's
how we get people to get you know 10
years later they're still transformed
from an experience that was one weekend
we all want to be able to change the way
we feel that's what I spend my life
showing people how to do and what most
people know is emotion is created by
motion the way you move determines the
way you feel you have 80 different
muscles in your face 80. for most people
this is the largest area of unemployment
in the country you know they use their
May the face the same way they feel the
same emotions over and over and over
again so what I was saying is I have
this deal with myself called priming
every day I say look you've got to have
10 minutes for yourself you don't have
10 minutes for yourself you don't have a
life and and I'm not going to hope I
feel good I just got back six countries
in 12 days I was in India two days ago
wow I woke up here and wanting like
feeling like somebody ran me over the
truck but you got yourself psyched up
but the way I did is I do this process
since 10 minutes I put some music on I
do this massive change of my breathing
so it radically changes the way I feel
and then I do this three-step process
first I do three minutes of gratitude
where I think of three things I'm really
grateful for and I associate I don't
think of it over there I feel it and the
reason is when you're grateful you can't
be worried it can't be fearful when
you're grateful you can't be angry and
anger and fear are what screw people up
most in their relationships and their
life and their business so I wire myself
I'm saying to you that most people want
to be happy but their habit is to be
worried or pissed off or frustrated or
stressed and so they're they've got a
high way to stress and they got a dirt
road to happiness so I wire myself I've
got a highway to gratitude which changes
all your emotions and then I do a
three-minute process of kind of a prayer
for my family and friends and then I do
a three minute process of the top three
things I want to accomplish purpose I
see it is done and I feel I'm done in 10
minutes so sometimes I go 20 but my deal
is 10 so there's no excuse not to do it
[Music]